[Applause]
these screens this Gary Harris did Jamal
Murray and then he knows that portal got
hit on that last naturally he's one of
them and that's what he does drop in
times no ditch inside - Harris for the
nice layout I've just watched he never
thought that the pass would be made well
when you play against Denver Denver is
one of the top teams in the league in
scoring to over 80 percentage fits it
back out to Barton they just call him
thrill his teammates do you're gonna see
the dump there's the double-team watch
see there's the rotator but he's a step
late the second unit guys come back
ready ready
Lia's on Aldridge and he's approaching
another triple-double focused wishes
jock itch / shoes guilty
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Joker just look the gear is in it and
put his hands up since see that's not go
waited waited push it in there and then
get the finish
Santonio is going to pick up the
intensity
yoke it's long range guys and that in
the first quarter for the first half I
should set end at the first quarter
wizard remember 16 of horns nearly
swiped at six on the shot clock
Morris this is the bunch that got to go
in form in the second period and Yogesh
puts it off the window that do that
this Denver team is explosive yo kids
goes to work with a hook T up another
michigan state Yogesh there are [ __ ] of
mind to here at the start and that's
what he needs to be he needs to go to
work
Dokic backs his way on portal spins
Spurs wanted a travel no pitch goes
right at it this is the yogic you want
to see all the time is when it's not
about you passing it's about you scoring
that the objects the object of the game
is to get that ball and put it back out
and get set up because he isn't the
quickest don't let that make you think
he doesn't have game I don't care how
slow it can happen team knows it right
now that they have to do it on the
defensive end until the possession with
the rebound
[Applause]
you can put the floater nuggets trying
to avoid the slow start and that might
do it
go kids with the done Nicola got things
going with a dunk and we're tied at 11
rebound right there yogic corner the key
eight to shoot
oh what a pass by Joker and a cut by
Gary Harris watch work Gary Harris comes
right he's gonna set this great just bad
nuts goes right to the basket but once
again around the corner goes Murray
[Applause]
and then the head fake just a head
beauty get the slap you can look at that
window there's there's no space there
well there was a little space well yeah
you know that's about the size of a
basketball
it's the seven minute mark of this first
quarter Nuggets winning on this floor
earlier in this series as young kids go
strong got a deep and a flurry of moves
in yo couch has two more on the floor it
kind of gives them the pump fake step
through comes back to where he was
introduced at nope nice footwork there
just Clarisse for the Spurs development
system undrafted and hits a three and
there is Harris inside he scores Murray
washed it into Yogesh six of the shot
clock
[Music]
[Applause]
yecchh the three that's making lemonade
right yeah that's a busted play and they
get a triple balls hit in his hand and
he's shooting he's feeling good about
his shot now Spurs had a 10-point lead
at the corner the back on top nevermind
Larry change his hat Jamal Murray to the
bass up the foul
look at these guys work and I mean a
little push off there on Mills maybe but
I just garden works so hard to get open
every - that with Murray there is Joe
kitch they cleared he goes to work on
our just incredibly difficult shot that
he makes look easy
see if Murray even sits down over there
tries to stay loose wide open [ __ ] it
back and throws it down with two hands
between DeRozan all to death 12 assists
also so they've done a great job of
getting the teammates involved and
knocked everything down but what
Denver's just lived on that play I'd say
yeah
Murray to yoke it's been a great - bad
combination in your kitchen with a nice
move to the first bucket of the game a
little look that way comes back the way
he's really clever with the ball is
having none of that
yoke it's got to go quickly here with
one on the shot clock oh my goodness
are you kidding up and over the
backboard
and this would look like your old
teammate Henry bird right baby look at
that shot he shoots the sky high up over
the barn
look at that behind the glass yet birdie
could do that shot sat for about four
minutes and the Nuggets outscored the
Spurs seven three with the oak it's down
and yolk gets a little one footer that
was at home instant offense drama cola
yo kitchen he's got eleven now six all
the timer
look at that Brian one-legged step back
tough shot superstar to get back up to
Chris for the Joker his joke on that
offensive loom this takes his time he
turns in you see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
on the floor trying to help Murray now
good pass
Nicola Lucas you could not let that pass
in a better spot match up between those
two and it comes a little earlier this
is on the timeout you see the Iceland
step up screen by Millsap
and throws a rate where it has to be
look at that rate on the side of the rim
goes up and Murray makes it easy looked
at the coach's head good job but Nuggets
can add to their six-point lead
yo kitchen
eight baths by yogurt look at that kind
of looked away catches them sleeping and
Yogesh ninth assist phenomenal shot that
sent portland into this Western
Conference semifinals nice pass young
kids to Millsap and if your yogurt you
can't do anything else besides what you
took it's a great job by day but he said
I tell you what you may get three on
that but I'm going to come down and this
is why I like it what Yogi's take your
time big fella oh yeah little one-legged
runner and you throw it up there then
shot a bad shot like like nothing had
happened
Denver in the bonus here all tied at 53
Yogesh goes to work on Kanter he scores
at the RAM just a feast down below it's
little shot fake now he goes and able to
get his own yoga kicks it to Craig for
three
full of nuggets
everything plows through yoga chat he
goes to hang that minute hesitation
yeah and the scoop with the left hand
what a player who's too athletic for
those guys that haven't gone there
Jamal Murray finds yogic look at this
pass Parris goes to go first
[Applause]
eight finish but I mean yogic season
come in and look at this oh look at the
spinny has to put on that ball great
finish by Harris by the pass to great
job Collins comes over to contest and
then you can do or in a row before the
missed by Aminu and now Harkless puts
another three ball in three threes made
yoga Jensen Torrey Craig no contest in
there the second quarter in Game one
and now yo kitch
passes up a three on the drive is that a
little hero step up Pickett was Nikola
yo kids this is the one where a
throwback to me kind of little head fake
there then it doesn't the gyro hangs in
the paint razors get back well after the
miss pass to Murray all the way in and
the Lakers go at all set up by the
chokers this time it's the big man to
the guard and an easy two for the
Nuggets no kid he did exactly what you
were about to say he was going to do but
you had it Millsap he goes to all
start for the Nuggets here in this
second half foot Torrey Craig maybe get
back in this ballgame so if he does
check in this place is going to go crazy
just look at this pass break to the
final five hole McCullum scoring the
ball as well as ten in the second half
13 for the game flurry amused by yoke
it's so pretty
check in cannon goes right to work on
yoga she gets a block with five fouls
now he pushes it ahead Morris on the
drive yoke it's right there but a
two-handed Jam
underneath winning oh my god we've got
him but tell you what this is a nice
throw ahead then you get in there he
doesn't quit on the plate his teeth
right to point blazer lead four minutes
gone by Murray from yo kitch lays it in
those two have tremendous connection
it's a second series and big shot to
this career he's always been a fearless
shot maker great fake by yo cats and a
beautiful touch yo kid straight past
great catch and finish by Craig how
about the read of the mismatch so a
three goes down and look at Yoker or
could score it all three levels but this
is what he wants to do sees a mismatch
pinpoint Pass nice pass back to Yogesh
and yo get inside for two and one you
see the connection between Murray and
yokas games so they put them in a
two-man game on the left side of the
floor it's just the two of them right
Craig is there two offensive rebound yo
kitch spinning and finishing so
beautifully done on the low block by the
Joker now it goes at Kanter and finds
Morris on the way
yo gets with one - shoot floats it up
and in what did we tell you though right
this guy averages 30 more touches
absolutely dynamic all year I'm fake get
that defender commit and put it on the
deck big fella how about the touch role
in yogic it's amazing he could say play
our game of it that game being defense
how about that berth challenge oh what a
finish by yo kids going under the hoop
and getting it to go watch how quickly
the spin comes he just he senses it
that's just a few yoga tries and the
choker says way to they get a load of me
they have been hunting
and this cancer did they try to do it
again great past yogic Spartan with the
finish but what a look by the Joker
where does he get all these toys the
mall Murray and the timer at 5:00 Yogesh
drives kicks it out
here's Murray and he got a three ties it
at 107 Blazers by two inside two to play
Millsap crickets we're tied as Millsap
finishes good switch defensively scored
ten points at about a seven-minute span
in the first quarter but has not scored
since and inside Paul Millsap the first
bucket of this second half shot clock
down to four here goes Murray gives it
up yo kids passes up on a three now
he'll take a long two and another one
off the window the second time tonight
the Joker has hit the glass from
straightaway yoke it's on a right-handed
Drive jump hook is good what a sequence
by Nikola yoke it's unfinished and look
at Yogesh one foot again just a nice
little soft shot where it is struggling
and not on the floor McCollum has
delivered Murray mrs. Mills
and align his Murray left-handed layup
is good and their yogic look for on the
shot clock backs down Lillard didn't
take the shot gives it up instead and
will Barton buries a three pointer
yo kitch Lillard ends up on him yo kids
with one on the shot clock dumps it off
and Harris scores as a whistle
and Celt a basket by yogic he gives a
little fake and he dropped it down and
there are literally no time left on the
clock even at two apiece at the bench
squat on Monta morris joins our bargain
and easy look yuck it sets up Millsap
just a couple of years ago at the
Atlanta Hawks he averaged 24 in the
playoffs
nice catch Krieger that finishes Terry
Stotts where the timeout this pass
throws it right over who can get it only
Millsap lays it in man behind the arc
was just 2 for 9 was Lillard so the
Nuggets with the ball and there goes yo
gets to the hole and he'll score with a
left hand
much this past it's a nice little split
past gets it people come in to challenge
them goes up wrong legged left-handed
but look how soft this is you know it
just hits the rim and dies its beat
Seattle 1994 May 7 what a significant
moment that was as foggy goes hence on a
gum no foul call but a big thing right
now is can you defend Denver and then
also can you get easy baskets that pass
by Yogesh that's one of his strengths to
Craig empty trip but the line here's
Bartlett is gonna break spark off the
bench no kitchen at point five to go or
creates havoc with your defense as the
game moves on Greg made the last three
that's two in a row for Torrey Craig
come to Nuggets no partner
I decide they had them mismatched the
head Ravens did his job staying between
yo kitchen the rim you gotta secure the
basketball at the outstanding defense
but give yo kitch credit they go right
to yo coach Collins on them
yo kick misses gets the rebound
[Applause]
Mauri looking for an opening yogurts
down a lane the runner is going